we have to talk about Kanye because
Kanye was a thing I don't know anything
about Kanye I used to call him Yee
instead of yeh because I really didn't
know the difference okay okay so Amanda
was this a good move by President Trump
to bring Kanye into the Oval Office 100%
I mean I want to inject that meeting
into my veins I mean incredible I mean
he just expose so much of the left I
mean we literally saw a CNN panel call
him a house n-word or or I mean it was
just outrageous they're calling him a
traitor to his race you just you see the
group think of the left and you see that
you cannot you know any if you don't
tell that line you were going to be
called mentally ill for instance which
is insane I don't remember the media
calling Kanye West and he said George
Jeb Bush doesn't care about black people
I remember them calling him you know
traitor to his race or mentally ill then
so this exposes the left so much Emily I
know that you also are Kanye West Han so
your words are valuable okay good
I think Kanye West was the right move
for president Trump honestly I think we
had eight years where Obama brought in
every Hollywood celebrity Under the Sun
they spoke to people they spoke to
people who don't particularly get
involved in politics and Kanye said it
himself it wasn't that he was on the
outside it was on the that he was on the
outside of what everyone else was
thinking and hey if Kanye can get it
done then more power to this is the
question so Shawn neither you nor I know
anything about Kanye West's is my
impression but with that said there's
been a lot of talk about Republicans
making significant gains in the black
community do you see any of that
reflected in the polling not significant
gains but you know if you look at
younger african-americans or not as as
clearly Democratic is the older
generation I mean personally I just look
at the Kanye thing and I think it's
proved we proof we live on the weirdest
possible time but but but you know look
if the Republicans are gonna do outreach
if they're gonna make improvements in
the african-american community this is
the type of thing that they need